aquí vamos a reagrupar números completos
tenemos este número 675 que es igual a 6
centenas o 600 más 7 decenas o 70 más 5
unidades voy a copiar y pegar esto dos
veces para que veamos diferentes maneras
de reagrupar los ok vamos a pegar esto
aquí y lo pongo acá muy bien vamos a
hacer otra copia y esta va a ir aquí
abajito y ahora solo nos falta una
tercera copia que ya es la última y la
ponemos acá
muy bien ahora una de las formas que se
me ocurre para reagrupar es tomar estas
seis centenas y quitarles una de manera
que queden aquí cinco centenas y agregar
una centena a esta parte de las decenas
de manera que aquí en lugar de tener
siete decenas voy a tener diecisiete
decenas y además se me ocurre que de
estas escenas voy a tomar una y se la
voy a pasar a estas unidades y ahora
luego de tener 17 voy a tener 16 decenas
pero en las unidades voy a tener 15
unidades ya no 5 es decir si lo vemos de
este lado a estos 600 lo dejé en 500 y
lo siento de aquí los agregue aquí aquí
agregue 100 de manera que aquí en lugar
de 70 me queda 170 y de estos 170 tomé
una decena de manera que me queda 160 y
esa decena la agregue a esta parte de
las unidades de manera que aquí en lugar
de quedarme cinco unidades me quedan 15
unidad es otra forma de hacer este
reagrupamiento es por ejemplo de estas
seis centenas voy a dejar solo cuatro
aquí y una centena la voy a repartir
aquí en las decenas de manera que me va
a quedar 17 decenas y la otra centena se
le agregó directamente acá de manera que
no va a tener cinco unidades voy a tener
105 unidades ahora viéndolo de este lado
aquí voy a tener en lugar de 600 voy a
tener 400 100 van a ir acá aquí voy a
tener más 100 de manera que aquí en
lugar de 70 voy a tener 170 y de estas
centenas otros 100 u otras centenas va
para acá
aquí agregue 100 en las unidades me va a
quedar en lugar de 5 unidades
voy a tener 105 unidades otra forma de
reagrupar lo que me está ocurriendo a lo
mejor quitar todas las centenas de acá
dejarle en cero y aquí agrega
cuatro centenas a las decenas de manera
que aquí me queda 47 decenas y en las
unidades me va a quedar 205 unidades
viéndolo de este lado aquí me quedan 0
se van a ir 400 ó 4 centenas de este
lado y me va a quedar 470 en lugar de 70
y las últimas dos centenas las paso aquí
a las unidades quedando finalmente como
205 en lugar de 5 en cualquiera de estas
opciones de reagrupamiento si ustedes
hacen la suma de cada uno de estos
números les va a dar la cantidad
original 675 es exactamente lo mismo
sólo que estamos poniendo diferentes
cantidades o reagrupando las en las
diferentes posiciones de las unidades
decenas y centenas